i now call the prime minister elizabeth
trust
mr speaker
in the hours since last night's shocking
news
we have witnessed the most heartfelt
outpouring of grief of the loss of her
late majesty the queen
crowds have gathered
flags have been lowered to half-mast
tributes have been sent from every
continent around the world
on the death of her father king george
vi
winston churchill said the news had
stilled the clatter and traffic of 20th
century life in many lands
now 70 years later in the tumult of the
21st century life has paused again
her late majesty queen elizabeth ii was
one of the greatest leaders the world
has ever known
she was the rock on which modern britain
was built
she came to the throne at just 25
in a country that was emerging from the
shadow of war
she bequeaths a modern dynamic nation
that has grown and flourished under her
reign
the united kingdom is the great country
it is today because of her
the commonwealth is the family of
nations it is today because of her
she was devoted to the union of england
scotland wales and northern ireland
she served 15 countries as head of state
and she loved them all
her words of wisdom gave us strength in
the most testing times
during the darkest moments of the
pandemic she gave us hope that we would
meet again
she knew this generation of britons
would be as strong as any
and as we meet today
we remember the pledge she made on her
21st birthday to dedicate her life to
service
the whole house will agree
never has a promise been so completely
fulfilled
her devotion to duty remains an example
to us all
she carried out thousands of engagements
she took a red box every day
she gave her ascent to countless pieces
of legislation
and was at the heart of our national
life for seven decades
the supreme governor of the church of
england she drew on her deep
faith she was the nation's greatest
diplomat
her visits to post-apartheid south
africa and to the republic of ireland
showed a unique ability to transcend
difference and heal division
in total she visited well over 100
countries
she meant she she met more people than
any other monarch in our history
she gave council to prime ministers and
ministers across government i have
personally greatly valued her wise
advice
only last october i witnessed first-hand
how she charmed the world's leading
investors at windsor castle
she was always so proud of britain and
always embodied the spirit of our great
country
she remained determined to carry out her
duties even at the age of 96.
it was just three days ago at balmoral
that she invited me to form a government
and become her 15th prime minister
again she generously shared with me her
deep experience of government even in
those last days
everyone who met her will remember the
moment
they will speak of it for the rest of
their lives
even those who never met her
her late majesty's image is an icon for
what britain stands for as a nation
on our coins on our stamps and in
portraits around the world
her legacy will endure through the
countless people she met
the global history she witnessed and the
lives that she touched
she was loved and admired by people
across the united kingdom and across the
world
one of the reasons for that affection
was her sheer humanity
she reinvented monarchy for the modern
age
she was a champion of freedom and
democracy around the world
she was dignified but not distant
she was willing to have fun
whether on a mission with 007 or having
tea with paddington bear
she brought the monarchy into people's
lives and into people's homes
during her first televised christmas
message in 1957
she said
today we need a special kind of courage
so we can show the world that we are not
afraid of the future
we need that courage now
in an instant yesterday our lives change
forever
today we show the world that we do not
fear what lies ahead
we send our deepest sympathy
to all members of the royal family
we pay tribute to our late queen
and we offer loyal service to our new
king
his majesty king charles iii
bears an awesome responsibility that he
now carries for all of us
i was grateful to speak to his majesty
last night
and offer my condolences
even as he mourns
his sense of duty and service is clear
he has already made a profound
contribution through his work on
conservation
education and his tireless diplomacy
we owe him our loyalty and devotion
the british people the commonwealth
and all of us in this house
will support him as he takes our country
forward to a new era of hope and
progress
our new carolian age
the crown enjoys
our nation in jaws
and in that spirit i say god save the
king
[Applause]